two welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
um this is where we come to learn and
grow
you know we are casting off negative
energies
and embracing the positive energies that
are in the world like a dream catcher
for life that's what i'm calling the h3
podcast now
good vibes only right ela why
why are you so offended at the thought
of good vibe a dream catcher
yeah dream catchers they they catch bad
dreams you only have good dreams so i
have a dream catcher for good vibes
what i never liked those yeah i don't
like them either to be honest
today's episode is sponsored by
expressvpn god bless them
and just a quick announcement the teddy
fresh x spongebob
the collaboration that took the universe
by storm is back online at
teddyfresh.com
today we are joined by the i i
tend to say prolific but you're
definitely not prolific
but you are you do what you do is great
although there's not many of it i think
you're getting a lot better with those
intros
well thank you very much great it's
better than prolific i think
last time you said something about uh i
think
luke skywalker or something like that at
some point
i think i think great is just take that
just simple
and to the point what does of course is
idubbbz
who has um
among many other videos but today has
released
his second feature length documentary
called the ice cream man about to know
that
oh no the ice cream man
you're not saying you know you had a
problem with uh oliver tree last time
where you're wanting to overstate words
for his like song yeah
i think that's a habit of you so
yeah um what was the name of the song
that you were trying to change
you were trying to tell them tell them
don't let me down yeah yeah
yeah you're right maybe the you you you
you artistic types like to reduce the
the words
yeah it just flows off the tongue a
little bit better
ice cream man is the name of his new
video out right now about the
the uh dax flame how would you describe
dax flame ian
you know him better than i yeah i mean
he's a little bit socially awkward but
also not uh i think he's a bit of an
oxymoron
a lot of the comments that i'm saying is
like whoa he's so
introverted but also he's really
extroverted
what's the deal with that so i think
that's a pretty good
way to sum him up like interesting you
know he's an actor he's an artist he's
comedian so he's like doing all these
very
like you know outgoing activities
and uh you know but that clashes i think
with his
sort of more natural personality which
is he's a guy who's just
a little bit shy a little bit awkward
but yeah
um when you sent me the unlisted link i
immediately noted i was like dude you
have copyrighted music in here what's
the deal with that are you crazy like
what are you
crazy and you told me you had actually
gone to a publishing company
and licensed the music for quite a bit
of money i would say you know for
for a song in a youtube video but you
were having technical issues
yesterday when the video was supposed to
go up was it related to that
yes it was it was it was
i don't know everyone has the has every
youtuber has the problem with like
specifically audio
more specifically music getting
copyrighted and like
it just felt like a good opportunity to
experiment to see if it's like a
like uh something that we can do in the
future
uh you know if it's not too much money
it's sort of hard if you ask the average
person how much do you think it costs to
license a
a piece of music like i don't think
anyone could really even ballpark what
it is because it's so
subjective like are you a person
with money because then who knows how
like infinite the amount they could
charge you would go
but i you know it seemed pretty
pretty reasonable at the start but then
things got more and more complicated
and we realized that it's just like this
time it wasn't worth the
effort we went through a lot of the
effort but in the end we just replaced
it with like
just some royalty free where you did
yeah
oh no way yeah originally we were gonna
use
uh california dreaming we were like oh
this is the perfect
song for the intro really artistic
really nice
um but it's like it's such
a [ __ ] web of like who owns what
there's going to be like
maybe 10 different people who own the
rights to a single song
and a single song is is broken up into
different categories maybe
it's uh the lyrical portion the master
license
the instrumental all these different
things so it's just
it's a lot harder than you'd think i
think it's a much better idea if you're
trying to use
good music on youtube to just contact
an artist directly and uh and use their
work or try to get permission are you
comfortable saying how much
you you were prepared to pay for these
songs
yeah so for california dreaming
like it was it's a [ __ ] good song
super popular yeah
i would have been willing to pay
probably up to
15 grand on it wow
uh but again it's it's it's all relative
right so like did you and you never got
it
how long no they they they never even
really like responded
so that's why you know movies and tv
shows and all these big networks they
have like whole departments
just for actually licensing it's it's a
[ __ ] nightmare
you can't do anything but then
ultimately what what will happen is like
you
ended up paying to license a song or you
were planning to
and then they claimed your [ __ ] video
right right so
we what we had to do is we had to nix
the california dreaming idea so we went
to
uh sort of a a a song
that they were confident they had the
rights to use um
and it wasn't as good but we were like
this is a good experiment
we upload the video instantly claim yes
i kept pounding them beforehand like
is this gonna get claimed if it gets
claimed i need it to disappear real
quick
yeah they just like it's this weird
divide
where it's like it seems like it's uh
like old hollywood and a bunch of
[ __ ] antiquated people
who get the licensing rights to these
songs but
youtube is you know so so new
and fresh that they're they're clueless
on how to like navigate how to
get rid of a claim or anything like that
and it's like a week-long process
the truth is that guy who's licensing it
probably doesn't even know
the guy on the left hand who's in a
claim farm somewhere in india or
or wherever yeah
yeah that's what they are they're
straight up claim farms they have
bounties on channels like
i've i've literally heard this from
people inside youtube there
there are claim farms where people are
paid bounties to watch
channels and find any copyrighted music
in it and so they get a commission on
every
video they're able to claim yeah it's
fun yeah
it's crazy so there you go well it was
worth the shot but
um on that note though i also noticed
just in general the production quality
seemed really
well made nice talking over your mic
[Laughter]
[Music]
we got an extra cameraman this time uh
my buddy ben was doing a lot of uh
secondary filming
so we were just trying to it looked
really good
i liked that stuff yeah it was great it
was very polished yeah
is this the new interest of yours the
documentary because i've noticed
they're basically encrypt me if i'm
wrong it seems that you've
pivoted away from the content cop and
towards the document
the docu-series yeah i mean
i i'm getting old
i know you're not i feel that my my
interests are changing just a little bit
yes i'm not going to say that content
cop's gone
but maybe there are some things
but it's not about me is it
i've been recommended from quite a few
people yeah i know
yeah yeah that would have been a good
one
yeah uh would you do content cop
on cups oh [ __ ] that's crazy dude what a
crazy
idea you should put on the content cop
uniform or go to a police station and
[ __ ] with that would be fun yeah i like
that idea
um so there is a content cop that you
are
maybe working on or mulling well i'm not
going to say that
because it's not i mean it's definitely
just like you have people in the
crosshair
no no no no you don't even have i think
in general it's more ideas in the
crosshair rather than people
um so let me write institutions perhaps
oh the police
oh no i'm not content copying the police
i'm not going to do that
maybe maybe i do like the idea of going
to the precinct and
whipping my dick out you might get
killed if you show up in a uniform and
start [ __ ] them
i think there's a high chance of being
murdered um well i do find that
the comment you made about you getting
older and you're interest changing is
interesting because i've kind of gone
through the same thing where
you know from my from my perspective you
have
you know it when you're constantly like
looking for people to go after and um
you know you're constantly criticizing
people for all this and that i mean
you know as you get older these things
start to become a little more trivial
and
maybe it's not the kind of energy you
want to be putting out into the world is
that
is that kind of where you're at when you
say that uh for sure
it it comes across as especially when
you give it more time
to to sit on it and uh
yeah i just i don't know it's
it it really isn't let's put it this way
it really isn't difficult
to make a commentary video anyone can
sit down and criticize someone else and
i think
it just like it's it's becoming a little
tired for me
uh if if other people want to do it i
think there's a place for it but
it's just becoming you know i've done
enough of it
i think uh you know if i do more i think
it just needs to have a little bit more
of a purpose or a point behind it rather
than just
you know let's make fun of this guy for
his lack of a chin
right yeah yeah no i feel that um
no i went through the same thing you
know it's like the the format itself has
become first of all so
prevalent on youtube that uh
it's really you know it's like by the
time yeah that's how i feel too
i don't know how better to put it yeah
but but on the contrast of the content
cop i feel like the docu-series is
almost
the antithesis of the content cop but
instead of
you know criticizing people you are
finding
people who uh kind of you know
living in the shadows of youtube a
little bit and and rising them
up do you feel that that is maybe the
the are you intentionally trying to do
something like that with your
docu-series
yeah i i don't think there's uh any
i'm not like actively choosing to like
be less negative
or uh you know bring people up
i don't think it's an active choice but
it's like i think
by nature when you go and meet people
uh you form a connection and things in
general are just going to be a lot more
positive
when you actually have a connection with
someone uh personal connection you meet
them
you know and that's i think that's in
general why a lot of
you know uh commentary videos will come
out and blow up is because it's uh it's
you know if i i'm certain if i
you know met some of the people that
i've made videos on in the past if i met
them in person first
there would probably be sort of a
diminishing motivation
to make a video about them because
you're not going to see
this weird persona that they put out
there you're going to see something a
little bit more real something a little
bit more human
more complex yeah you know these these
two characters like you did
your first one was on airsoft fatty and
your second one i was on dax flame
i mean these are dudes who probably
catch a lot of [ __ ] on the internet from
people who
don't understand them right so
i find it interesting that um
you know you're going out there and
meeting them and then
all of a sudden these guys are portrayed
as these celebrated
great you know very very sweet
individuals and i wonder if uh
yeah it feels very fresh it feels very
different from what's on the youtube
landscape so i appreciate that
you know that perspective yeah thank you
i yeah we
they definitely have you know their own
like set of fans and everything i think
like with with dax
as an example like i definitely went
into it because when you're
when you're creating one of these videos
you sort of want to
have a goal you don't really want to go
into it blind because it's like well
what do we make this video about
like you can't just follow someone
around and be like yeah do your normal
routine you got to have like an event or
a purpose
um so like with people like dax i think
i went into it thinking
yeah this guy's awkward let's [ __ ] it
let's [ __ ] with him
you know there's a few awkward questions
that i don't think made the cut
it was just me trying to poke and pry
thinking like
he's awkward let me ask him some
uncomfortable questions to make it even
weirder
but then i realized like as time went on
like that's like the opposite approach
that you should be taking
you should be i think feeding into
what the particular person is
comfortable with
because when they're more comfortable
they're a lot more willing to like put
themselves out there
and express themselves in an interesting
way rather than just like
you know beating your head against a
wall trying to make
the funny thing happen right right right
how's everything with um your girlfriend
anissa now that kovit has slammed the
world
she's stuck in canada it's crazy that
here in america we are we have failed to
contain the virus to the point where
canada
has closed the border on plague written
america
and so your girlfriend is stuck in
canada right is that the current
situation
yeah and let me just say the canadians
better be very scared because i'm coming
up with a 250-page
common-law marriage dossier to present
to the
customs officials so that i could go to
canada
really you're going to present it yes to
border control yeah
and and they're gonna let me through and
i'm gonna bring the covid with me
[ __ ] it yeah [ __ ] them
sorry canada you're screwed are you
being careful how how
are you existing in the colvid world um
what's your opinion on all this nonsense
madness
you know me man anti-master all the way
yeah
no not actually yeah i know that make
that clear not
at all even remotely uh yeah
i mean it's very easy i i talked to um
the my my friend dane who uh
filmed the documentary and edited it he
uh
he was saying how it feels very normal
to him this covid stuff because he
doesn't get a house all that often
anyway
so it's kind of ridiculous hearing some
people like
complaining about not being able to go
see friends and
go to the bar and he's like what the
hell and i feel kind of the same it's
like
yeah what am i leaving the house for
anyone
do you go grocery shopping yeah so you
put on a mask when you go to the grocery
store
oh yeah i'm only in 95 up how
how paranoid do you feel when you're at
the grocery store on a scale of one to
ten
paranoid yeah i mean
maybe a three a three yeah that seems a
healthy amount
i think it's mainly like the touching
things because you can get
really into this ocd mentality of like
right where it's like okay there's the
carts there's credit card reader there's
all these
items and objects to touch on the
shelves so it's like
it you can kind of overthink it there's
like a lot of like viral things of like
plastic over a credit card keypad or
something and it's like
what's the point of putting the plastic
on there you're just still touching it
and other people are touching it
so it's like i think it's that idea
where it's like well yeah what isn't
being touched
do you carry around hand sanitizer with
you uh i did for a while i ran out
recently and i just assumed
that yeah i'm not gonna be able to find
more
i bought i actually found something we
just found some i think it just became
available
on amazon yeah i think they're using
some real [ __ ] smelling
uh hand sanitizer now though they're
using like
something other than isopropyl alcohol
oh for real
yeah it smells a little funky we got one
that's super thick
and it's like really gross i was at the
gas station
i don't know what's in it well because i
went to the gas station i went to the
clerk
i was like hey do you guys have
sanitizer expecting him to say no
because this was like peak
madness and he goes yeah i got this and
he reaches behind the counter
and he just gives me like what looks
like a bottle of sunscreen
clear a label that's in spanish
and then but there's no you can't like
turn it over and squeeze it it's like
got a top like a like a bottle of water
and a huge so you got it so you just
gotta like squeeze it
right out i would have never expected
like bootleg sanitizer
i was like you know what but whenever i
use it there's like a really thick layer
on my hands
that does not go away yeah i don't think
that's the real deal in fact i'd be
surprised if
it kills the virus
[Music]
sounds like the dried semen
um but i did go on amazon you know and
we bought
i think we got ripped off i think they
are upselling a little bit
yeah amazon's like you can't charge
times 20 you can only charge
charge times three so we ended up
spending like 200
on like a crate of hand sanitizer
but um it smells great they made it with
alloy
so there you have it people alloy
yeah alloy it smells great no
uh no not alloy
hello hello
e it's pronounced aloe yeah oh that
doesn't
sound right i could spell it
a-l-o-e that is it
alo english is your first language ethan
supposedly some people say my first
language is
uh comedy
[Laughter]
yeah i've told people that yeah my first
language is comedy
well how how are your fans reacting to
kind of
i think a lot of the you know your
rise to fame was during your time the
content cops were like
remember not rise to fame but like a lot
of growth
yeah uh during that time that's fair so
are you
experiencing any kind of kickback from
fans who are like [ __ ]
documentaries and fear and good vibes i
want
idubbbz [ __ ] on people you get that
uh no like it's one of those things
where it's like
i think it's pretty i think the the simp
debacle has really helped that
where it's like i'm i'm purging sort of
inadvertently a portion of my audience
that really wants to see me
go for the throat you know um
content cop your own girlfriend bro
yeah exactly can you can you explain the
simp phenomenon
explain it i mean i i can tell you that
it was like
my video was uh either
really well timed or really poorly timed
i don't
depending on your perspective or i mean
more specifically why are people calling
you a simp
i mean
yeah i just wanted to set it up for the
audience obviously
i know why i mean we've also talked
about it well by the way guys i want to
make it clear
i'm not upset with ethan right now yeah
why are we fighting
friendly okay okay you just you just
prevented like
five videos
thank you ian i appreciate that yeah no
people are [ __ ]
stupid we just spawned 20 video essays
um yeah no ian's girlfriend
made a only fans which is i guess does
she even do nudes on only fans it's more
like
more no no it's i mean the reason sexy
photos
sexy photos i guess right it's it's
super easy to justify when you're like
yeah like this is the [ __ ] girls are
doing on instagram
and no one's whining and bitching and
moaning over that
yeah but as soon as you start taking
people's money for that content it's
like oh that's
that's too much i expect girls to show
me their sh
junk for free yeah or up in a sense no i
actually
so it does seem to me that a lot of
people who are
criticizing it are are people who you
know
are just happy to find an opening to
criticize you because
for the longest time i feel like you
know there was never really a [ __ ] in
your armor and that
you were always very careful with your
why are you smiling
no reason i i mean i'm smiling because i
i agree yeah yeah but i think like
there's like these con these commentary
people right
who are just looking for content they're
like piranhas anywhere they can get it
and then all of a sudden you see an
opening on like uh
idubbbz who's kind of the the great
uh criticizer who who is beyond
criticism and then all of a sudden
it's a great headline i don't think
anyone's actually offended by the fact
that your girlfriend
it hasn't only fans i think that it's
just they see an opportunity for a
for a video yeah i think you're exactly
right i mean
and it kind of shows in like the i think
the
the people in general who who did get
upset or did make videos about it it's
kind of like
uh i don't know like the people who are
like actually critical of it like
they're not
really in a mainstream sphere they have
their
you know uh soapbox that they're
speaking on
to their particular audience but
i think it's it's actually super
positive
that it ended up this way because i
think for a long time
when i'd have a uh you know first
interaction with someone meeting someone
for the first time
i think a lot of people sort of expected
me to
like immediately roast them to do a
content comp on them
people just being nervous like oh yeah
you know they see me in the videos being
an [ __ ] and it's like that must be
him in real taking notes on me
yeah yeah so it's it really is a
positive thing to
to i guess in a way take this
hit to make me humanize you know maybe
yeah exactly it humanizes me and makes
people real
realize that you know i'm just like them
you know i'm not it's not funny because
you're actually like
kind of the opposite of that in person
like i think
it's a softy you're a really nice person
yeah you know i would
say that's what the image they have of
you
yeah right it's like especially with the
videos that got popular it's like i
genuinely
you know got [ __ ] roid raged when
talking about like keemstar whoever else
because
you know it it made me net mad and you
know when you see i think people who
have that uh
uh who who that's like their main form
of content
is like just kind of dogging other
people or they got you know well known
for it
that definitely i think solidifies what
you think their personality is
yeah you know it's funny when we went to
creator youtube's
creator summit where they invite a bunch
of creators out to new york that was a
wh how long ago was that
a few years probably um almost four
years or three
i don't know i might be making it yeah
maybe you're right anyway i went out
there and met a bunch of creators and we
never
really rubbed shoulders with creators
before
and i heard this so many times the whole
time they're like you're so not what i
expected
right i'm like dude i'm not like on i'm
not here
yeah yeah i heard that all the time and
i find it like
i'm just surprised how many people are
even comfortable saying that
i think it's just their gut reaction
it's just but it just
overwhelms them every time they see me
that i'm just not what they expected
not anymore though right like that that
was probably why i don't
i don't meet anybody anymore but i don't
think any people wouldn't say that about
me now
yeah yeah i think it's the same fact as
ian
with the content cops because at the
time we were doing mostly reaction
videos
yes well i think uh uh in the
documentary tay
zande actually made a really good point
i think about that
where it's like there's this expectation
that you
kind of have a bit of a persona and that
is very true
i think for youtubers where you can
kind of make a video edit out all the
parts that make you look human
and put it on the internet and i think
you know if any of these youtubers if i
decided to you know live stream tomorrow
or something like that where you saw a
more uncut
version of me um then you would
probably get a you know a
more well-rounded idea of the type of
person i am
uh you know for better or worse you know
that's kind of what always interests me
about the podcast is that
for the longest time we have these
perfectly manicured videos
where you can portray yourself in the
best possible light however you want
you have the best perfect take you say
everything perfectly but then
like we did our show live for like two
years you know
and for me that was like the biggest
challenge imaginable to move
from these perfectly manicured videos to
doing a live
stream for two hours and to me i
personally
thought that you know i was being more
authentic and expressing my true
authentic self
but um i think it's a little bit
tragic that um you know
when you attempt to do that you
you remove some of the context that you
can maybe add in
in a post-production or anything else
you can do a lot people people don't for
some reason people don't give the
benefit of the doubt in this case where
like i think for a lot of people they
just
they sif a lot of people sift through
the content looking for
you know to make a thesis about me and
yeah it was just i don't know in the end
it was it was just
it may be too vulnerable i guess i don't
know what to say because
a lot of people started hating me i feel
like since we started doing the podcast
live like just specifically the live
aspect
you know and there's there are
definitely times when i would look back
and be like i wish i could have edited
that
and said it and re-shot it or done that
differently but you know that's kind of
the nature of the piece right so
i don't know i don't regret it but uh
i'm kind of glad it's not live anymore
yeah because
absolutely i just said the n word like
20 times when i was super
we cut that out
right that comment in your documentary
was the one that really stood out to me
about how
it's it's funny to think that in the
beginning of youtube
it was even more extreme where people
would be completely disappointed
to find out that you're different in
person
and that like what's portrayed in the
video is not exactly a hundred percent
what's what you are in your life where
like today they people expect it more
they have a better understanding
yeah like you the video version of you
is probably a little more exaggerated
and stuff yeah i thought that was a very
interesting yeah it was interesting
especially in regards to dax flame
because of how
he's such a mystery yeah
they uh they definitely have like it's
it's
it's interesting to know that they do
that
to like like you guys are i think pretty
protected by
like or you know all youtubers are
protected by being able to edit their
videos and whatnot and be able to
portray what they're putting out there
but to think that there is this section
of hollywood
k-pop stars musicians whoever they have
it to the nth degree where they have
like
agents and pr people actively like
editing their life as their life is
happening
which is just super [ __ ] they have a
real handle
i mean look at someone like tom cruise
right that dude has like 20 handlers
with him at all times
yeah i just saw this one uh of [ __ ]
gordon ramsay like going off on sofia
vergara
on like a late night show he was like
poking her and doing a lot of like
sexual innuendo [ __ ] and it was like
holy [ __ ]
like i i can't believe that he
he i guess got this far like since then
i guess his
personality's been reeled in all right
let's go to a quick
break and uh we will be right back with
the
not prolific but excellent he's very
nice
very nice individual very interesting as
well
hi dubs
have you ever watched the office if you
have you probably know it's based on the
uk
series also called the office but what
if i told you there are nine
other countries with their own version
of the office that you've never seen
i'd be shocked well you probably didn't
know about them because they're not
usually available in your country
but you can access content available
around the world
with no geo restriction when you use
expressvpn
that is crazy i didn't know that there
was all these episodes or they see
other shootoffs of the office that's
amazing
expressvpn lets you control where you
want sites to think
you're located you can choose from
nearly 100 different countries giving
you
access to content that isn't available
in your region
if you like watching shows or movies
expressvpn is a must-have
for less than seven dollars a month
expressvpn lets you access
thousands of new shows movies on netflix
amazon prime
disney plus and tons of other streaming
services it's a no-brainer and look i
know you all got tons of time on your
hand with covid you're stuck at home
you've already watched everything on
netflix
see what's on in netflix uh japan
for example you know
and it couldn't be easier to use just
fire up the expressvpn
app on your computer or tv select a
location
and hit connect expressvpn is also
incredibly
fast it doesn't slow down your
connection
you can stream content in hd quality
with no issues at all so get the most
out of your streaming services
today at expressvpn.com h3 if you use
our link you'll get an extra three
months
free of expressvpn again
that's expressvpn.com h3 expressvpn.com
h3 please support our sponsors
thank you to expressvpn god bless
teddy fresh x spongebob squarepants is
back by popular demand it is now live on
our website at teddyfresh.com
we've got the old and the new this
classic
uh teddy fresh spongebob hoodie
is back and we've got new colors as well
an aqua
and shady cove look at this beautiful
embroidery
here gorgeous oh my goodness oh
oh oh oh you love it you love it you
love it
that's the hoodie let's go back
you've also got the uh embroidered
hoodie
which is classic you know you can't go
wrong with that and all these beautiful
colors you got purple
crystal waters coral
all water themed names of course because
you know how we do it
this is a really beautiful item the
shirt
quality is amazing you've got the teddy
fresh friends
spongebob plus
we need to name our bear ela don't do
you think we need to name our teddy
fresh bear
i never thought about that what's his
name i wonder
jeremiah jeremiah was a bear
oh i just got claimed uh
uh we got the embroidered tea we got the
patch tee forget it forget it we got the
long sleeves the beanie the hat
you know the drill um really great items
exclusively at teddyfresh.com
that's it guys uh thank you for watching
let's get right back into
it we are back
with idubbbz items let me ask you
something
um the whole simp thing was like the
first time you were on the receiving
end of catching [ __ ] on the internet
how did it feel to kind of be on that
end of the uh
the old [ __ ] gun
it it hurt it hurt me
it's the worst isn't it well i think
you're being sarcastic but
no no i'm not sarcastic see that's part
of the problem
is without this people would just think
i'm
i'm above it and all that no it hurt i'm
human
it hurt me hurt my feelings to hear
people
say things like simp cuck
[ __ ] well it's not so much that
what they say it's like just the net the
the scope of negativity aimed at you you
you feel that you know
you can't just dodge and also i can't
i can only imagine that as a couple too
it must be difficult
to both get it and then as a couple
you know it's like a lot i'm certain you
guys yeah
would understand it i think it's brought
us like a lot closer together because
it's like
we're in this together yeah you know
when when [ __ ] hits the fan it's like
yeah you don't really have anyone to
rely on you're not going to get
fulfillment by reading comments you're
going to get it by
from each other yeah so yeah i mean it's
it's only strength in the relationship
um
apart from her being in canada right now
but uh
it's it's overall a good thing you know
it's not
uh it's not negative i think everyone
needs to
every content creator needs to
experience
some of this during their career because
it's important it gives you perspective
on
what it feels like whether or not you
want to
engage in it when it happens you know if
if someone's getting dogged on
like you're gonna you're gonna think
twice if you've experienced it before
so it's important i think for everyone
to get a taste of it
i'm perfect i'm i'm more than happy that
this was my
controversy well you didn't really do
anything that was kind of the thing that
stopped me right
which is why i'm like i'm i'm cool with
it
you know but i i was kind of
i won't say i was shocked that it became
a thing because knowing the internet i
wasn't surprised but people
somehow found a way to make it seem like
you did something wrong when you
literally did
nothing so i found that whole thing kind
of perplexing it frustrated me did you
were you frustrated by you're like
what exactly am i being criticized for
um
i think the only frustrating thing was
when people
couldn't read between the lines in like
previous videos
i think a lot of people would i made a
green screen comp
compilation of me basically saying look
at this [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ] and all this [ __ ] and
like people were using that
some people not everyone were using that
as like evidence of me
being hypocritical as if that's even
too much of a bad thing uh that's
literally everyone
but they were using that as some kind of
evidence and i'm like that
like that was a joke i wasn't like i was
saying look at this horror to a greens
nobody yeah you could put yourself or
your grandmother up on that green screen
and that's
that changes the context or a hot dog
whatever you want
yeah yeah so that's a good point it's
just that
frustration i think i think some people
also watch like
the uh tana mojo content comp and
thought like
he hates this type of person so they
they're lumping like a general type of
person together where it's like
the amount of times i've seen like the
meme where it was like
you were meant to destroy the simps not
join them
there's like like a [ __ ] uh star wars
media yeah and i'm just like rolling my
eyes like come
on like what is this weird expectation
like you were meant to destroy the sibs
ian
you have lost your weapon so no i don't
know where
in the charter of the formation of my
channel i said
the purpose is to eliminate thoughts
[ __ ] and sims yeah i find that
interesting it's almost like
they're they're projecting
their but this whole thing is like so
hateful towards women isn't it it's very
strong
yeah and they're just projecting like
their in-cell
insole dumb on you yeah i think the the
misunderstanding comes in where
like a lot of people think that like
what we're saying
is that you need to be okay with it
like you need to be okay with our
relationship or whatever it's like
no it's perfectly fine if you don't want
that in your relationship
but like right yeah that's not what
yeah what's being advocated it's not
saying this should be the new world
order
yeah every person's wife should be on
only things right
like i'm okay with elo doing only fans i
think we'd make a lot of supplementary
you said you weren't i'm okay with you
bang on only fence
who do you think would get more near you
well as soon as he thought of the dollar
signs he was like maybe it's not a
terrible idea
we needed we could supplement our income
um yeah
well i mean that's it right it's like in
the in the context of most people
talking about this what i've noticed is
a lot of people
do these sort of like what would you do
in this situation
and it's like it's really not important
because
it's like that's not even in question no
one is talking about you
or your relationship that's the whole
point it's like we're fine with people
not doing it if you
if you value the money more than
exposing more of your body to the
internet
like then more power to you that's great
i think that's
what anisse and i value we're like oh
yeah we're fine with that
and i've i've watched anisa's video
about it
about if she regrets it and i thought it
was really interesting that she said
it's actually been really good for her
not only financially which probably has
been huge
but um even just for her own
like self-confidence and
like being more just more out there and
coming to all
absolutely i can tell as if you know
myself i have a lot of
insecurities so i could understand what
she was talking about and it sounds like
it was really good for her
so that's i think the number one thing
that people sort of get wrong when
they're talking about it
and i would say it's it's
more likely than not guys or or
not guys a person who's in a
relationship who feels like
not fulfilled or like like they're not
contributing their fair share or
whatever the
mentality is i think a lot of people
don't get
that it's not it's not always about
money like money's nice that's obviously
part of the equation but the other part
of the equation is
i need something i want something
anise's streaming wasn't going
like that well it's not a [ __ ] rocket
ship she needed to do
something else and that's what she
wanted to do and yeah
you know it's it's more about purpose a
lot of people would say
idubbbz is a [ __ ] millionaire he
makes so much money why can't he
like that's sad that's sad if if he
if he can't just pay for her life like
what the [ __ ] it's so
that is not what it's about i'm missing
the point because she wants to be
fulfilled and
i totally get that and um like in our
case
it's different because we started
together the youtube channel
but even at a there was a point before
we started teddy fresh where ethan was
actually doing most of it like he was
doing the editing and he was in the
videos
and it felt like i wasn't pulling my
weight and it was
yeah there was friction i felt so
restless and like just
not good about myself and it's like okay
i'll do the dishes because
you know i might as well do something
but this is not my calling
you know and yeah no totally yeah but a
lot of people online would want your
calling to be doing the dishes well
that's what i was going to say is that
it's the same people who would say
call you a simp like they don't they
understand that a female
relationship could couldn't be fulfilled
by just being provided
but you know also what's funny if she
wasn't like that and she was
just fine with using his money they
would call her a gold digger
right and then she would be that person
i mean that was happening for you know
basically three years of our
relationship is people saying that
you're just doing this for clout and
whatever else and it's like
if you think she's doing it for clout
you're sorely mistaken because
she hasn't seen a [ __ ] ounce of
where's like
uh yeah all i saw was only gone
[ __ ] yeah tons and tons of [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah people are [ __ ] cruel
man
it's probably probably wasn't been easy
for her to be your girlfriend because
up you know because for this the express
you know fact that people are are
looking for ways to criticize you
and i think by proxy a lot of people saw
her as an opportunity to get at you
absolutely yeah no i mean i've seen that
over the years it's just like
yeah there's nothing with you let's
attack your girlfriend kind of thing and
it's like
i mean she makes it easy because she
live streams
and she speaks her mind and [ __ ] you
guys would know that like well
the more like i i would be in the same
[ __ ] situation
guaranteed if i had as much uh
content out there online as anissa does
and everyone would be in the same
position yeah
because it's like you're just putting
yourself out there day after day
entertaining people with zero cuts for
hours on end
right you're gonna say stupid [ __ ] all
the time
and by the way for you not to contradict
yourself
over the course of like let's say we
were doing this podcast for over like
three
well over maybe even four years now
we've been doing it a lot of those years
was live
for like this whole hip the hypocrite
label is
somehow become like uh it's too much of
a throwaway
yeah it doesn't hold a lot of weight
because it's like
yeah like it's like they mean
okay no you don't need salt you don't
even need to like
um unpack that at all it's just like
you're a hypocrite you that's like the
worst insult
you can lay against somebody on the
internet for some reason yeah
and how is it possible to not contradict
yourself
over four years of yeah well even even
as i'm having this
you know conversation i'm like i'm
thinking back into the past
at moments when i called other people
hypocrites and i think one of the
moments was in uh
i think this is maybe the only time in
the keemstar content cop
um and even that makes me like hesitate
because to even talk about it in a more
mature evolved way
because i'm like some fucker's gonna
take that [ __ ] from that video and be
like
uh hypocrite it's like what the [ __ ]
yep you're absolutely right yeah
it's an absolute minefield yeah it is
man
that's why it's amazing that you've been
beyond like beyond uh
criticism for so long but it's very
[ __ ] easy
to be without criticism when you don't
share anything about your life and you
just
you're very proud that's kind of the
only way to do it right mm-hmm yeah
i could have avoided this whole thing i
could have
broken up with my girlfriend like that's
what a lot of people suggest right like
oh don't worry you could solve this
whole thing by just breaking up with her
can you imagine what are you what do you
live in
humans oh my god like i wonder would
they be happy if you made a
content cop on her when she announced
the only fans i'm announcing
today that i'm breaking up with my
ex-girlfriend anissa who is selling her
body
new video in one hour
like oh my god yeah dude
there's a lot of pissed off there's a
lot of pissed off
disenfranchised people on the internet
yeah i i do feel hopeful though because
i think it's just
uh it's a lot of young people or a lot
of people who are still you know finding
themselves
yeah and figuring it out you know i was
you know making a lot of these content
cops when i was basically
you know 20 25 years old
uh and it's like i mean that feels
pretty late in life but
the age i'm at now i'm like yeah i was
sort of an immature kid and
a lot of the arguments really don't hold
up over time and
they might even not be you know worth
making in the first place it's
so i don't know with time all this is
gonna
be pretty [ __ ] irrelevant yeah that's
for sure that's for sure
i try to i try to bear that in mind as
we go through [ __ ] you know especially
on youtube
you go through so much drama and like
everything feels so
so has so much gravity but i mean the
[ __ ] that we
that people get upset about on the
internet generally is just so
so irrelevant in the scope of even five
years
or even less like two years one year you
know what i mean
um i want uh i want like
uh generations past zoomer and
millennial
to to start populating places like
twitter and stuff like that
because i feel like right now we just
have a very
homogenous group on you know the youtube
comment section on twitter and
everything else so as soon as you start
like populating that with this absolute
[ __ ] mass of people
who honestly don't give a [ __ ] uh i i
think you'd start hearing more
uh well-rounded opinions
i can't wait for that the zoo the
zoomers are like
the younger generation right why are
they called zoomers
they zoom around they [ __ ] run around
they have the zoomies
have you not seen like a dog getting
real excited to go to the park
yeah oh the zoomies right isn't that i
thought that was tippy taps
happy feet or some [ __ ] yeah so do you
actually know what zoomer means
no i thought it was just a younger
generation like boomer zoomer
exactly well it's generation z oh okay
i like the zoomers they seem like nicer
like they're all they're like inclusive
and sweet and they like
seems like they like each other more
yeah yeah
absolutely but they're also going to be
the ones that [ __ ] cancel you
right that's true some of them i mean
they're they're sweet and it comes from
a good place
yeah what they think is the right thing
in a lot of cases it is like morally or
whatever but
it's not using the um i don't know
brevity is the right word but like it's
it's not using the context or the
you know the wisdom they're lacking a
little bit of the wisdom
you just got can't yourself canceled
dude yeah
you just got zoomed
i'm gonna get zoomed in
they're going to be saying that i'm they
wouldn't call me gay
zoom shame say what they say
insensitive you're just exist you are
yeah they could definitely say all those
things about you
yeah so um what else
i mean you look great you've been
exercising you look really good
yeah let's see it kovid's been treating
me well you've been what kind of
workouts you've been doing
lifting a lot of weight damn wow i could
probably dead lift the whole klein
family
you think so hell yeah i doubt
lifting like two uh
25. you're not yeah you you can't even
lift me
i hope my family well to be fair i make
up 90
of the weight all right
uh percent of the climate change yeah
there you go
so is the mustache here to stay
is it a gag is it a goof
why would you ask that i think it looks
good i don't know
uh no what do you yeah what do you guys
honestly think be honest
i don't want to hear from everyone i
think it's zach
sorry i got this frog in my throat
i personally think that it suits you now
i'm not an advocate for a mustache for
just anybody but in the case of your
face i think it suits you well
i i think generally i'm not a fan
in general like in my my
first connotation of mustache is usually
not good but
but looking at you right now you look
good but you've had the mustache for a
while haven't you
yeah it's not a new thing no i'm not too
new but it is controversial
yeah okay i don't know why i think
there's just been too many
creepy dads with mustache yeah it's hard
to make
it it needs a comeback
um all right okay well he's requested
the opinions of the other of the others
so go ahead guys
i think it looks good i've been choosing
regrettable facial hair my whole life
there's like a weird
appeal to it but it only you only see it
in your own head
and then everyone else like i see myself
as like kratos when i have a beard
then everyone else is like that's why do
you have that correcto
i like your buddy it's good i think most
dudes with beards kind of picture them
as
themselves as kratos really i where what
if i could never that he's the god of
war
i agree with ian i think it's rockstar i
think it's badass and i think you rock
it
zack yeah zach always has nice things to
say
that's a zoomer he always says nice is
that a zoomer
i am a zoomer oh so zoomers are the best
yeah zoomers are nice wow just don't
cross there is hope yeah
we should start doing the olympics but
divided divide people up not by nations
but by like
generations yeah yeah the zoomers would
be all nice and the boomers would be
like
you know when you see the soccer fans
and they're drunk and fighting and
they're flying confederate flags and
[ __ ]
and they won't be like team players too
no
it's bad over there in boomer of town
yeah do you guys think we should uh oh
dan what do you think of it
i think it looks good i i i've noticed
uh
i don't know if you're the trendsetter
here but it's becoming uh
i feel like mustaches are coming back i
see a lot of people with them yeah
and just in the last like i would say
two years it seems to
there's a good mustache come back mark
or maybe you're right i think it's a
group
think kind of thing i think you could
take full credit right
mark rubio has one uh gus gus johnson
and eddie yeah
those two guys are both rocking the
stash these days it's kind of mustache
it's making a comeback
yeah you know what would make it look
better
is if you go back to the beats headphone
haircut
what happened with the beats headphone
haircut that never i was assuming that
was
some part of some project no i just got
the
the beats because i thought this would
be a banger uh tweet
oh dude i was hoping that being a video
or something man
it was in a video but just sort of
passing aside
uh it was pretty good man who did that
just some barber
you just went and they were like i'm up
for that because when i generally just
show up at barbers they're not that good
yeah i mean i i told them what i wanted
and
it was super [ __ ] awkward he
he was like the new guy kind of thing
and like i think he thought
his barber homies were like pranking him
or whatever barbara prank cause yeah it
was just me and i showed him this
picture of the
the beats haircut and i was just like uh
give me this or whatever the meme saying
is um
and uh he did it he i think he used like
a
he pulled like a top of like a spray can
or a like a hairspray cap to make the uh
the headphone part so he was like
shaking around that's really good
that's bro he pulled out all the stops
did he get a nice tip
uh yeah you got a nice tip good i just
want to make sure
big tip well we actually have um
dax flame which is
is there anything else we need to
discuss ian yeah one more thing
uh i'm raising chickens i got a family
of three chickens
they're beautiful they got nice shiny
coats they're
losing a little bit of feathers around
their necks i'm not sure what that's due
to i think it might be mites
so i got some poultry dust that's
apparently really good for warding off
mites and other things
and they're great they're [ __ ] out
like
five or six eggs a day or at least feels
that really
it's a lot like five or six birds or
between them
between them okay that's a lot of eggs
my goodness yeah i can't keep up with
them so i'm trying
if anyone's got suggestions for what i
can do with these eggs
i can send you guys eggs i don't know
how they're gonna hold up in the mail
you can make a quiche yeah we've been
making quiche a lot
i love the quiche it's really good you
know what i've been doing
take like broccoli or spinach cook it
down with some oil
and then you take like eight eggs put it
in a
uh what do you call that dish it's like
a baking dish really it's just like a
glass
right right souffle dish i don't know no
what
flavor why are you so offended by that
it might be something
what are you stupid are you stupid
where'd you come up with souffle israel
souffle is a dessert
yeah but in america no it's not it's not
yeah but i thought souffle was a dessert
yeah
i still think of it as a dessert but it
but i see i think it's a souffle
or similar google super please after i
offended you so much
is it a pyrex yes spirex
souffle dish let's see what that comes
up
hang on okay
okay so english is my first language
stop
you know fine i know eli doesn't make
any mistakes
i mean god yeah over
okay here hold on while we're criticized
saying oh ethan
this is my first language what do you
call that dessert in
hebrew souffle okay so there you go you
see so
like we're on the same footing ethan
what what if you did like uh
like a bit on the show where it was like
not like a spelling bee
but like a pronouncing bee or like a
that's kind of funny where you maybe
compete against like a fan or something
like that you bring people in
so test your knowledge on words so like
i like that the guys
the guys would prepare like a kind of
pronunciation
yeah and definition i mean yeah i feel
like i
okay i mean i think i would i mean i
think you guys think that would be
funny i think i would do better than you
think i think it's funny it is funny
or we can try and spell the words the
way ethan thinks the words
are meant to be pronounced i think you
just have a talent of
mixing it up you're actually really
smart it's
okay now i'm really smart you are it's
not related
well i am i am mildly dyslexic
so but it's kind of funny it's but i
can't believe it
it really is funny especially when you
make it the point
it's the whole point of the show to do
it it's because it's distracting when
you just sort of
casually say yeah it's got alloy in it
and i'm saying yeah
you want to be the first contestant yeah
we'll have to call it um i'll
i'll be the nick cannon i'll judge it or
host it
you want to be like nick cannon yeah oh
wait no nick hannah's kansas
can't be nick you don't want me like
nick cannon like give me the cannon
we shot nick cannon out of a cannon we
said
tata no what were we talking about take
the eggs
crack them in a dish a bake safe dish
whatever you want to call it
and get a shitload of cheese i mean like
a [ __ ] like way more than you think
that you would need
and then double it and then you take the
broccoli
and the spinach cooked you put it in the
egg and with the cheese
you bake it at 350 until the top is like
a little crispy and i'm telling you dude
that [ __ ] is fire you don't it that's
it it's the best three simple
ingredients so there you go that's my
suggestion
okay i'll i'm i might do that the cheese
thing sounds a bit dangerous
you have to do are you lactose
intolerant uh no
but just like that quantity of cheese
just seems not like uh
not good i'm trying to cut and trying to
bulk up
i'm well it's a [ __ ] load of protein bro
oh i mean i think
yeah you can do a little bit of cheese
no it needs cheese i'm just telling you
all right i'll douse in cheese fine
no it needs a lot of cheese otherwise
it's just like a ton of egg and
vegetables and it's just like what am i
doing here it needs the cheese
right awesome all right enough of that
but yeah i just want to talk about the
chickens that's it
so okay you're just wondering what to do
with the eggs
yeah yeah well i worked cleared up i
think i i got it all off my chest
what do you feed that chickens how much
how much maintenance do chickens require
oh not too much i like letting them out
of their coop once every
a couple of days let them roam in the
backyard for
a day let them pick things out of the
yard they're
they're cool they're kind of like
william osman said they're kind of like
insects
and i kind of agree with that assessment
they're really quite stupid because you
think a birds are like they're smart
like parrots and all these things they
talk
but chickens are really quite stupid
problem solvers they uh they're not
quite like dogs but you shake like a
bag of mealworms or something they'll
come running up it'll feel like they're
a dog
but then you realize if there's like any
like little barrier between you and them
they can't
navigate they won't get to you they're
yeah and you don't feel like
bonding bonded with them they're too
stupid to bond with
yeah too dumb i open my arms for to have
them come in and give me like a hug or
like rest their
naked necks on mine but they don't do it
they're just like
pecking at my hands pecking at my feet
like are you made of food
and would you feel bad at any point to
slaughter them for
for me oh not at all i wouldn't yeah
i've considered it a couple times
because i'm like
they're just a bit of a hassle would you
kill them yourself
uh and probably not you would take them
i'd send them to a farm or something
that's interesting that you're you
you're so unbonded with them
so yeah yeah i mean they're but that's
it i mean back in the day you know
yeah people well people slaughter like
really smart animals you know
so is this a covey thing you just wanted
to have like eggs
uh no it just happened to correspond
with covet it was just a weird little
coincidence
let me ask you this to the value of the
eggs
like monetary value how does the
monetary value the eggs compare to the
amount of money you spend on the
chickens
do you think you're making money i think
it's probably a wash
um uh the coupe is obviously like a big
upfront expense
if we eliminate that pretend that that's
not part of it it's like
you're maybe paying a little bit more
than you would
uh at the store however it's
it's pretty cruelty free and i'm
actually kind of uncertain
why um some vegans are like
uh a bit upset i think with the prospect
of
uh raising your own chickens because you
can make sure that they have plenty of
space
yeah and and all that but i think it's
just the general concept of using
animals as a resource period
yeah that's the problem but it's super
symbiotic it's
nice interesting um
and how are the egg how's the egg
quality compared to what you find in the
store
oh no it's it's the same it's the same
everyone that you talk about like is
gonna be like oh my gosh you've never
tasted
anything as good as a home-grown egg it
tastes exactly the same
[ __ ] yeah did they do they like uh
cock-a-doodle-doo
in the morning i think that's a rooster
yeah that would have to be a
male version where are all the males by
the way you don't have
males no i don't think there's much of a
reason to
i think you if you have a lot i think
you want to have like one
male rooster for a certain amount of
females either to feel
safe or something some [ __ ] like that
but i will say to the your point of
cock-a-doodle doing in the morning they
will
make uh i can only compare it to like
someone blowing out a toilet when
they're [ __ ] out their eggs
they make a lot of strained noises oh my
god
[Music]
what time in the morning are we talking
i mean
basically the time when you'd hear a
rooster like that's 5 a.m 6
uh seven a.m i'd say do you think your
neighbors can hear your
chickens [ __ ] and eggs oh they they can
yeah
damn i'd be pissed about your neighbor
like this [ __ ] you should offer
them some eggs
yeah that's true
um wow that is very weird i think that's
cool
no it's not weird how dare you but it's
also weird
it's a little a little weird but i think
it's cool too i mean you connect with
the
you can be cool and weird right where it
right in santa cruz everyone has a
bumper sticker that says keep santa cruz
weird
there you go i think everywhere that has
graffiti has keep soon so weird
keep portland [ __ ] keep san francisco
not jen uh what is it
gentrified whatever right right what do
they say about l.a they say
keep l.a keep l.a
yeah should i call him dax or madison
you can call him whatever you want i
think
he he kind of enjoys getting a variety
of
comments so let's figure it out let's
navigate that space
we are going to bring on the the uh
the subject ian's subject of his new
documentary dax flame
he is the i want to say infamous really
one of the
early early youtubers and uh
people would say an enigma i think
people the thing that you often hear
about dax is
people can't tell if he is doing a
character or if he's being genuinely
himself that's one of the fascinations
with him
regardless he's a nice sweet guy from
all i can tell and i'm looking forward
to talking to him
so i'm gonna go take a quick [ __ ] we're
gonna do a little cut
and then we'll bring out dax okay it was
not necessary to say it well i felt like
just keeping everyone updated i'll be
right back well
with us we have dax flame
otherwise known as um madison
or theodore even uh as according to your
wikipedia page a man of many names
yeah what do you prefer to go by or do
you would not have a preference
well people tell me a little bit of
everything so i don't care but it's
usually dexter
no one calls me theory anymore um yeah
um why dax flame where did that name
come from uh
uh just like a 15 year old's version of
what i thought was cool at the time
and then if uh
that's just what i got famous with so
it's what i still go by but at the time
it was just what i thought was a cool
name obviously as a 28 year old i don't
like think
the same but i it's like my stage name
now because that's why i got credit
as movies yeah well
to give to to give you credit i think
that my pseudonyms that i was making at
15 years old were way
less cool than that they were probably
like uh
i'm trying to think of some of the dumb
names i had in video games you know what
i'm talking about
dildo saggins yeah
is with me to this day but i mean that's
something that seems to be cool
that's just being movie right that is
just being goofy no
what do you think about poop feast 420
that's my current uh
tag name on on my video games do you
like poop feast 420
but it depends what you're going for
yeah i guess that's true um how does it
feel dax i want to talk about the
documentary
you are the you are the subject of ian
uh's new documentary how do you feel
being
selected as the subject of a documentary
lucky yeah because because it was really
fun to do
got to make a game show that i've been
dreaming of making and i was thinking
maybe i would do a kickstarter for the
game show at the time
but who knows if that would have gone
through so to just be able to go
make it was awesome um and then now
um can you still hear me if i'm like
this
yes um now uh
actually now um
now everyone's watching it and it's been
out for like two hours or something and
getting so many views which is crazy and
my video is getting a lot more views
than it
ever gets so that's really exciting how
did it feel watching the documentary
the final product it's really fun to
watch
um it's really interesting to like
because you like you know you live your
whole life and to have someone else
summarize your life is interesting
you think you did a good job you think
he nailed you
oh yeah yeah uh it's good it's really
good yeah
um would you criticize it in front of
him
[Laughter]
uh oh no
what do you think dex let me ask you
this why do you think people are so
confused about you because
i'm sure the most common comment you get
from
everybody who knows you who meets you is
i can't tell
if you're being serious or if you're
kidding why is it that you think people
are so confused
i think just because probably i think
like 15 year old me was a lot more like
wacky and like
just manic and especially when i turned
the camera on back then
it's like you start to see that get
attention so i just would lean into that
so
i think that that's like
like they just probably hadn't seen
someone like
as similar to that although i could used
to get a lot of comments saying like oh
there's someone just like this at my
school so yeah i don't know
so this story in your most popular video
you say
you stole from your girl
uh the girl you had a crush on you stole
out of her bag
what was it the what pencils pencils
and you broke all over some pencils yeah
so
is that true you stole stuff out of her
bag
yeah well it it's just like an awkward
attempt at flirting that i try to avoid
thinking about these days but i'm open
to talking about it with
people because i know they're interested
in it but because when i
when i see that video i tell myself
there's no way this actually happened
but you stand by the fact that you did
take stuff out of her purse
for the purpose of flirting with her and
being like hey look what i found
yeah wow well how did it come
to fruition did you ever return the
items to her
uh i think i think he put it back in the
bag right in the store
yeah i i don't know if i ever took them
yeah i don't remember yeah
like i think i just snapped the pencils
yeah and put it back
and then maybe i took no no but you had
stuff with him he was on his desk and
he's like look at the stuff i took out
of her bag
some glasses yeah maybe a rainbow so did
you ever return it to her
anything that said i i don't know i
don't remember
i think i like maybe i was wearing the
glasses the next day or something
i don't know oh man
that's just it i think that's what makes
it so
interesting and confusing is because i
think normally
people who are in your position young
and a little bit socially
awkward wouldn't then make a video
presenting that concept to people and i
think the idea that just the fact that
it
shared makes it unbelievable well i
think whenever you like
are getting attention for something and
like you're getting a lot of positive
feedback
it just makes you want to like like like
do that yeah yeah did you have like
uh comedic influence at the time that
you were looking up to
comedians i liked i liked like listening
to stand-up comedy and stuff
um yeah yeah
i think i would just like listen to
people on youtube um
i like jerry seinfeld and uh
love jerry sniffle you like seinfeld
the show i i don't watch that uh
i think i watched it once when i got my
wisdom teeth out just happened
what they made you watch some [ __ ] when
they're working on your teeth
no whenever i had to take the
painkillers for a couple days
they're just like all i could do is
watch tv and that was what was on
okay let me ask you uh
when you made that video and i'm sorry i
know this is old news right this
this you probably talked about a million
times but i'm curious okay
you've made when did you know that it
was funny when you made this video
about stealing stuff from the your the
girl you liked to bag
or was it like a confession what was the
intention behind that video
i don't know i think i was just feeling
sort of uh hyped that day
so i was like i was hyped on hyped on
the girl
hyped on having uh like a lot of views
on youtube probably and
i just remember being really excited as
i uploaded it i was just like
and excited to go back to school the
next day and stuff
um but yeah yeah i think
i always knew that uh i i like i
i always got so many comments saying
that stuff was funny
so um i don't know like i think it was
like this mixture of
uh uh like
yeah just like uh right
yeah because i don't know i've asked my
husband
um how do you feel about being compared
people always say another thing i always
hear about you is
people say you're the andy kaufman of
youtube or something like that or they
compare you to andy
kaufman a lot do you accept that
comparison or how do you feel about that
i like some of it um whenever i've like
looked him up and stuff
i i like i don't connect
completely he seems a little jerkish in
some ways
but i did like i watched like the man on
the moon movie and stuff and that's
really good
um yeah but i guess what they mean is
like the
he had this he skirted the same line
right of not knowing
who the real him is where the real him
is and where the character
starts and stops for sure yeah
i think like i think like uh the mystery
element i definitely connect with
because
that's always been a big factor in like
people watching me uh
so so yeah there's always been like a
huge are
a mystery around my videos um
which i think uh is good
for people like entertainment like
like people enjoy that but when i
when i saw you in ian's documentary i
get the feeling that you
don't
maybe you don't really get where the
mystery is at
i feel like maybe you just do you
understand why people think that you're
mysterious or to you or you're just
being yourself i think i get some of it
yeah but i also don't really need to
examine it because it's like
right if i try and find a line and then
address the line specifically it's
better just the comparison
yeah the mystery is good so
yeah what do you feel about the youtube
landscape today because you were one of
the top the early early creators right
at the time i recall you were like 16th
most subscribed
channel with like 250 000 subscribers
just you have an idea
no uh probably more like 100 000 oh 100
so youtube
was in its infancy very much but you
were one of the top creators at the time
um obviously a lot's changed what do you
think now when you look at
kind of the leaderboard of who's what's
popular on youtube now
i actually don't know how to find the
leaderboard how it used to be because
they usually have like a top 100
where you click through uh so i don't
know like i can't identify the
leaderboard
but i definitely see what's trending and
stuff um
and uh my thoughts are i don't know it's
all fine whatever
um uh there's some i i like to watch
stuff i'll click on trending sometimes
and
find some stuff listen to music on
youtube and
um
it's definitely if you're a youtube
celebrity now compared to back bed
you're like a legit celebrity
yeah i thought that was really
interesting that you pointed out how
back then that wasn't the case and
today i guess it's true i mean it's
still kind of like
weird to think about but like youtube
celebrity is like
celebrity the audience is way bigger the
subscribers will be and you make money
now i mean back then you didn't even
make money right
yeah actually in high school i probably
saved up like 10 000
because after i was most popular then
they started to pay people like with a
partnership program so i was on a second
wave of partnership programs
so you did make a little money yeah i
think these days
you would uh probably like if you're in
that position you'd go up here on talk
shows like ellen and stuff and
like you know that's what the more route
that team
influencers go i think um
are you still working at the ice cream
shop no
no no that the shop closed down uh
in january from the sabotages
did you have anything to do with it no
i i don't think that played a role
but you know i'm curious what do you
think your manager will say when they
see that
part about the sabotage i don't know i i
showed it to my assistant manager she's
really nice um
maybe i'll send her this video and um
she was i never hated bird and i won't
actively say anything about anyone else
who i might have not liked
um but yeah i won't say anything
but uh if they found it
they'd be shocked
because you they probably thought you
were the upstanding
you know employee but no no they didn't
oh they did it
again no i was trying to get a raise for
so long it's such old news now
because then i went and worked at like a
cafe per week i worked at the sushi
place and then i've been living off
unemployment checks which has been great
because today's a lie
and uh you know i haven't had to work so
i've just been able to stay home and be
creative and
not worry about corona or anything so
that was really lucky but um
they didn't think i was upstanding i
don't think
but well then why would they be shocked
that you were giving away free ice cream
i wonder
well they'd be shocked that i wrote a
book that you wrote a book
but i did i did used to email the owners
and stuff and like
ask them if they would if i could ever
do an interview with them and stuff or
like
uh like emailed in this draw drawing i
did of them and stuff like that and
emailed the gm and stuff but uh
oh i thought the ga was fair so there
were multiple gm's there too
so it's an ice cream empire it sounds
like
yeah but then the whole place
well edit this out if it's not legal to
say anything like this but
the whole place like went bankrupt
eventually and um
i don't want to say anything else it
sounds like and the reason
because it went bankrupt is because
well that part of your book sounded so
funny
i um i actually immediately after
watching the documentary i ordered both
of your books because i
really want to read them and i thought
the cover looked cool too
yeah like oh thank you they're all on
amazon by the way if anyone wants to uh
support dax anyone wants to read his
literature
definitely head on over your your pen
name is dax flame right
all the books under that name yeah
so why is it that you think you were
overlooked for the promotion that you
sought so so passionately you're at an
ice cream store you're working your butt
off
you're keeping everything organized
what's going on
why did they give you reasons why you
kept getting passed over
how long did you work there 15 months
that's a long time a year in a few
months did you get any raises
in that so thanks for having me on the
podcast thanks for i don't know i
just heard me but um anyways thank you
you're welcome thank you for joining us
i think because uh people don't like to
pay so mr money so if you know that this
person is going to keep working there no
matter what
you don't have to pay them more so i
uh so the big corporate world
yeah well ultimately they did go
bankrupt so i guess maybe it wasn't uh
maybe they didn't have the leverage to
give you a raise after all
yeah so then so because they kept
promising this state this state will
give you the raise we'll give you a
promotion to like senior scooper was the
position
senior senior super yeah and
um and then i think that maybe they
would have followed through if
the money wasn't getting tight because
they
yeah so so who knows maybe i was mad at
them for the wrong reasons you know
always is it
the other side may i ask how much of a
raise you were pursuing
from fifteen dollars an hour to sixteen
dollars an hour oh that's what senior
scooper gets paid
is it was it about the money or was it
about the prestige
uh honestly probably the acknowledgement
yeah yeah but i know it sounds really
silly
to get so fixated on something like that
i i
at the time it felt important but
like i don't know but yeah
is it one of the worst jobs i always
feel like the
in the world yeah like giving the people
the different flavors i don't know why i
always feel like it's gotta be
a really annoying job yeah
i like talking to people uh that i
enjoyed
that i guess what i hated was like
cleaning and stuff there's so much
cleaning to do
and it was this really big shop so there
was lots of services to clean and stuff
after
closing and it stayed open late too so
i'm glad i'm not there
how many what do you recall any
instances of people requesting an
an absurd amount of samples
some people would sample everything and
i didn't mind that if they seemed like
nice and fun to talk to
but i did mind whenever they were like
like one thing that just popped into my
mind this like one
specific thing someone said to me was i
remember we had these
mickey mouse flavors for a bit uh
and uh and this
man was asking about this and i was like
we have three different
of the mickey mouse flavors and he's
like i really couldn't care less man
and then he started asking for other
samples are like thinking well why did
you ask
ask me and
was he by himself or was he with people
i don't remember
because i feel like that would be even
weirder if he was by himself you know
yeah you get a lot of weird people
did you eat i i noticed that in the
documentary
yeah you pre-empt you kind of finished
my question you got ahead of it
i was going to say is that in the
documentary you said you hate ice cream
is that a result of working there or did
you hate ice cream before you started
working there
well i used to love ice cream and then i
wanted to
try to not eat it for a week
and then i kept doing that and then i
started to like fruit
because i never liked healthy things
before that so then i was like i guess
my taste
buds desensitized a bit
so then fruit started to taste good and
now
i just try and stick with that because i
like smoothies so much
so do you think it's accurate to say you
hate ice cream because that seems maybe
a strong statement for what you just i
would probably i would probably enjoy it
but
at the time that we filmed the
documentary i was working around it
also and i despised but it was not only
ice cream that you said you hate it was
ice cream cereal and popcorn right
yeah seriously popcorn i hate because of
the texture that's a lot of really great
items
yeah yeah popcorn
definition of everyone's like favorite
foods basically
yeah well well let me ask you this
what's your favorite food
take your time too
are you very picky with food no i
i well i'm vegetarian i like meat a lot
but
i haven't eaten it for a while but um
i'm vegetarian
i like impossible burgers those are
really good um
burgers aren't that good to me
and smoothies of course but i feel great
right how could i how could i even ask
that
now in this smoothie your concert for
the smoothie show do you think it would
be funny maybe
to because it seemed like all the
ingredients were relatively good
and then people would would be they
would be going to choose an ingredient
and you'd be like oh don't choose that i
don't like that
it seems well i didn't understand that
those ingredients were placed there
for the sabotage round because yeah i
thought that they wouldn't pick those
like the granola you know same texture
as cereal
and uh see that doesn't syrup you know
what would be real sabotage
for me would be like fish oil or
something like that
i put flaxseed oil in my smoothies as
long as you can't taste it and it adds
some health
but that's what i'm saying it seems like
ultimately the goal is you still want to
end up with a relatively good smoothie
at worst
but what i'm wondering is possible
potentially
the sabotage yeah something really
disgusting like
tomatoes fish oil or something like that
you know what i mean
would you taste fish oil i think it
would taste very bad but maybe that's
funny
yeah then i would yeah that would be a
great sabotage thing
to destroy their chances of winning that
round i guess i will say
that this is something that i that we
struggled with when
when trying to come up with like the
sabotage idea
i think at one point i was like i had
the same thought ethan where i was like
yeah let's put a fish in there like a
big salmon you come out with a big
salmon
uh dane was like yeah we can call it
samintage
and it was it was one of those things
where i think there was just a
miscommunication uh
it almost seemed like dax just also just
wanted enjoyable smoothies like yeah
that's what it seemed like anyway
well yeah i think that that would have
been a good idea of the salmon or the
fish oil because
that would have been more obvious the
person would accidentally pick it
and i wouldn't say don't pick it yeah
that makes sense
well i would recommend putting the
sabotage next to the normal ingredients
either
but although if somebody pick if
somebody like proactively chooses a
sabotage ingredient you should probably
just let them
that just means they're a bad contestant
right
yeah but i don't want to put someone in
that position
because you saved us because we lost our
opponent
yeah the housekeeper crushed it i mean i
i was very impressed by her
yeah she won every round yeah she and
she kind of flaunted on that she flexed
on that guy too a little bit
didn't she yeah when he was having a
hard time opening the mixer
yeah she's kind of a legend yeah leticia
was awesome
you have you seen fear factor i'm like a
aficionado of that show
i think when i was a kid i saw it
because they used to make smoothies
and some of the challenges but they
would be i think i've seen that
testicles
and intestines and [ __ ] stuff like that
but like i think that might be more
entertaining to watch because
i guess maybe there's not a different
crowd but i just don't think i'm i just
question how entertaining it is to watch
somebody drink a delicious smoothie
well i think i also want to promote like
health and stuff through like
showing healthy ingredients so actually
that could be used in the sabotage
though but you're saying
combine the best of both worlds right
that's maybe that's what it
but ultimately you're the one that has
to drink it so maybe we have to
put other people up to drinking it
yeah if you don't also have another
reality show idea recently
today or yesterday but i don't think i
should talk about it yet okay
would you consider would you consider if
you make the smoothie
game show would you consider having the
winner on like in jeopardy
and maybe she can continue on oh yeah
that's what i would like to do have like
20 episodes
of that and then a 10 episode playoff
route where
best of like this person this
then ultimately there's a championship
oh there's like a bracket
yeah that's why we have to get rid of
corona amongst other reasons
but then if corona was gone we could
film this that's the main reason we need
to get ready
right i mean [ __ ] i need to i need to
know
i need that bracket [ __ ]
what are you looking to be doing
with yourself ideally like what are your
goals right now i don't know i don't
know what to do with my life but i do
know what my next steps are
like i'm always good at picking the next
thing um
but there's something i've been writing
but i don't know if i should talk about
it
not
well i don't know but there's a couple
things that i'm working on that i'm
excited about
a book or like a script or yeah talk
about it
it's okay i just have a new book i'm
probably going to put out in like oh
cool oh fantastic nice about quarantine
about 14 oh that's a great topic and
like i've had a couple business ideas
i've been working on and stuff but
like always i just like i have an idea
and i just like go with it and it either
pans out or it doesn't or maybe it turns
into something else
um so i just like go with that but
eventually i probably need to find like
a good job or like
or yeah figure something out but is
writing your
main thing that you like doing or acting
uh i love all of it
yeah i'm not sure if we included it in
the documentary but there was
we we did talk about a little bit more
in depth like
what his uh dax's goals
and dreams are like dream job and stuff
like that
and in general like uh it's just kind of
anything
creative and like within the
entertainment sphere i think he
he'd be down to do pretty much any of it
as long as it's not some robot job
i feel that i feel the i mean yeah you
know
i totally get that the hours are the
worst part of those kinds of drugs
what were your shifts like well just
like you never knew what your schedule
would be so
sometimes you'd work until like midnight
and then sometimes yeah i've been
there i hate them yeah that's right it's
almost like cruel and unusual to have
someone
work a shift at 8 a.m and then any time
during the week they might have to come
in
at 5 00 p.m it's like who can and then
they work till like 12 or 1.
i mean who can live their life so
unscheduled
what were you honestly young
my favorite job um
oh that's easy for me yeah it's easy for
me too
when i was uh when was this i think it
was during a summer
my parents made me get a job and i
really didn't want to work like fast
food just for whatever reason
i didn't i didn't look down on it or it
wasn't like that i mean it's a
you know i think all jobs are admirable
my brother worked at taco bell and
he didn't hate it but i just didn't want
to work in fast food
so i looked in the newspaper for any
opportunity
and i found this company at the time
they were paying 15
or maybe it was 12 an hour but it was
like good pay
for the time because this was a long
time ago the minimum wage was like seven
dollars an hour or something 725
so i was like [ __ ] you know 10 12 an
hour it's a little extra money i like
that
right off the bat the job was
first of all i went first to the
interview and they give you
this test uh
it's like a multiple choice test like
three sheets of paper you fill out the
answers i remember specifically they
gave me a pencil not a pen
which i thought i don't know why that
stuck out to me but
uh they were really horrible like just
you'd have to be
brain dead not not to answer these
questions correctly
so the bar was already really low i
passed the test
the job itself was going into huge
retail stores
like walmart's
uh targets
routes stuff like that you go in after
store hours
and you have a little laser gun and you
just scan
inventory to take inventory of their
stock
i don't know i guess back then they
didn't really have the technology
so they had all these people come in in
the middle of the night and just scan
[ __ ] right
so the hours were insane they were like
like sometimes we would start at one
o'clock one a.m
so i had so i'm by nature a night owl
i would say and so forcing myself to
like try to go to bed at you know
4 00 p.m was not
it wasn't just difficult it was
impossible so i would lay in bed
just trying to sleep i would end up just
not sleeping at all
getting up at 1am which is just ungodly
[Music]
and then driving you know
in the dead of night out into like
some [ __ ] retail store and i
remember one night i was so tired i left
my car keys in the door for the entire
eight hour shift
and then i came back i was like where's
my car my
keys i can't believe i lost my car keys
and i went back to my car and the keys
were in the [ __ ] door the whole time
that's how tired how old are you oh
probably like
18. okay and anyway the job the work was
just like beyond
inventory account right it was just
monotonous they were
they they had like these pros right like
they had like inventory ninjas who had
been there
for like 30 years and they were they
were like
they were making 15 an hour
and they were like scanning like like uh
you know it was high noon i've had to do
that when i was working in like a
retail shop and i think they do it like
once a year
or something and it was the biggest
nightmare well we were the cavalry right
they called us in when they
wanted it really good but the problem
was i sucked i [ __ ]
sucked at the job for some reason i
couldn't scan
accurately and then they would have like
because i was a noob they would bring in
like the uh
they would bring in the dark holiday of
scanning
to fact check my work and then they'd be
like dude you got the count wrong
like every time they'd be like dude you
got the count wrong that feels the worst
when you're already
in like a a job that you feel
like you're not better than but like
at least qualified for like bare minimum
and they come in they're like oh yeah
you're actually not doing your job
nearly as efficient
and good as you could be you know
and i was just the worst fi i mean i was
just
miserable dude and the people you know
the people took their jobs so seriously
who were these scanners and i just
thought
found the whole thing so [ __ ]
ridiculous um
my worst job that was my worst job by
far was a waitress
just i've i i had many like
many of those kind of like shitty
whatever jobs but
just in general being a waitress and
there was a specific
restaurant that was the worst social
club no
well that was bad but um i didn't i was
only there a week so
it doesn't really count but the italian
one oh what really that was your worst
job
yeah because the food wasn't good and so
it was expensive too
and it was kind of expensive and it
would
everything would fall on me from both
sides like the customers weren't happy
and then the people in the kitchen were
douche bags so it's like
you go to the kitchen to complain on
behalf of the customer you get yelled at
and then you go give a
bad answer to the customer and you get
yelled at so
it was like the worst job ever does it
sound fun
yeah i feel like that there could be
really high variance for
like a waitressing job like it could be
really good if the food's awesome
the chefs or whoever else is accountable
yeah and you have good customers but if
you have
any link in the chain is shitty it's all
going to come down on the waiters and
waitresses that's
do you have a worse job since we're
asking
the gap are you working at the gap
yeah tell me about that um
it's similar experience with you and the
late
night shift thing i went in for
general sales associate position but uh
it was like a
kind of a round table a bunch of people
applying for the job
young people older people and they just
sort of assumed that every guy there
was there to work warehouse like uh
do the shipping and receiving
uh and unloading of merchandise in the
morning so i got
tasked on that and it was the same
experience as you were
like i'm a night owl they want me to
come in at 3am
and it's like this [ __ ] sucks yeah
i was like there were there were days
it's not good but there were days where
i was like driving home
and it's like it's i'm
like almost falling asleep at the wheel
yeah there were some close calls and i
was just like holy [ __ ]
like it's good the roads are empty right
now
otherwise it would be over no so it was
just uh
i don't know it was like not good hours
and then also
uh kind of like dax's example people
constantly coming in and out because
they were giving a higher rate of uh
uh pay at the time ten dollars an hour
that was like really good
yeah um compared to the eight
uh minimum wage so
they wanted to work you really hard they
had like so they had a ton of employees
they wanted to work you really hard
for like eight hours a week or whatever
the
threshold was oh [ __ ]
god it's so crazy how they just game the
system to [ __ ]
squeeze people for everything it's very
stupid there was a reddit post recently
where
like i think it was mcdonald's or some
big company
was trying to show uh low-income workers
how they
could live after mcdonald's i saw that
you saw that
yeah it was so [ __ ] stupid
yeah it's a classic mcdonald's thing
where they had a budget they're like how
to make money
on minimum wage and it included a second
job
and zero dollars for heating yeah and
and didn't account
for like it it's like best case scenario
as far as like
your rates of like electricity trash
whatever else
it it assumes that you have negotiated
as a poor person
the best deal you can get for all of
these services
just [ __ ] bizarre
you know what was worse at that um
waiting job too that i was talking about
that
if you made a mistake like um
any kind of mistake like ordering the
wrong item for someone or
someone got out without paying they
would take it out of your tips
is that legal in israel because it's not
legal here i know i think that's
common in some i don't know i i've heard
stories like that
at least in california i think it's not
legal in california maybe it is in other
states
i don't know but that was so shitty yeah
it's so shitty
they also didn't pay us minimum wage it
was just tips oh so that's the crazy
thing in israel
is that i think it's actually like that
in some states too not in california
um they can just they don't have to pay
you even a minimum wage you just make
money in tips
which ends up being basically maybe a
tiny bit more than minimum wage
right yeah and super high variance in
what you're going to come home with at
the end of each day
yeah no predictability you can't [ __ ]
count on anything
yeah that sucks so um
dax may i ask you a personal question
i recently acquired a bidet
and before we went on i took a ship i
have a toilet
literally right behind us there's a
bathroom there and i used toilet paper
for the first time in a while
just i like to remind myself of where i
came from
you know to know where i'm going as they
say or whatever
what i'm wondering what do you mean like
like
like to stay in touch with the people
[Laughter]
well i don't i don't necessarily i don't
necessarily think that a bidet is so
bougie because in europe everyone has a
bidet
and you can buy like for example one of
our sponsors tushy they make an
attachment for 75
so it's not exactly bougie although i
will admit that ours
is very bougie um but what i'm what i'm
leading to
is what is your wiping uh ritual
oh just the pretty average toilet paper
yeah
from the front or the back
oh no comment no comment
well if i can give you my own anecdote
maybe it will encourage you to share
is that i think most peop most dudes
most dudes wipe from the back i myself
cup my balls in penis and wipe i scoop
out from the front and then back
i don't do that anymore because you do
that ian yeah i've done i i i
i don't cut my dick in balls but well
don't you
how do you don't you need to get him out
of the way no i'm pretty
like just facially aware of where my
rectum is and where the
dick and ball i just like to get it out
of the way i guess but i'm fascinated
that you go from the front because a lot
of people when i came out of the closet
as a front wiper yeah it was very i
caught a lot of [ __ ]
for it uh no pun intended and
um we did a poll that that showed
actually i think like
35 to 40 are front wipers
so our so i don't know if that
encouraged you to share if you're front
or back
but of course oh i'm probably more in
the majority there
you're in the majority yeah understood
what do y'all think is the key to
youtube success
changing topics that was like
talking about how you poop hang on dude
we can't steer that
you don't like the topic of it okay fair
enough you're listening to the key
to youtube success yeah this is it
what is the key the key to youtube
success
is well you know there's a couple
different routes
okay um there's
the easy and fast way
which is just you know talking [ __ ]
about people
and sensationalized titles and
thumbnails
so that's a really easy way to the easy
not i don't know if it's relatively easy
because you still have to make like at
least some
something compelling about your videos
but that's certainly the the easiest way
to uh just youtube
success or at least wreck or recognition
but the infinitely more difficult way
and i hate to say it almost even
impossible it seems like today
is the genuine being a genuine
person and just like i feel like to
succeed on youtube these days you need
some kind of shtick right
like uh
not to not to deride uh mr beast because
i think he's talented i like his channel
i'm just using him as an example is that
like everything needs to be like the
biggest and the best and the craziest
idea and he's really talented and really
good at what he does and i
i think he's a great channel and he's a
positive channel so
i'm not at all trying to insult him i
just think that
he is kind of the model of youtube
success right now are you familiar with
mr beast
yeah so you kind of that's like
unfortunately there's a lot of
competition for clicks and eyeballs on
youtube right now
and so you know making genuine grounded
content
you can you can certainly garner a fan
base but
i guess success is is obviously
subjective right
like i think it's very important to like
uh
just like uh decide what uh success
means to you
because i think like mr beast is a great
example of how
big how successful you can be but there
are definitely a lot of channels
making livable good incomes
with a relatively small audience or
niche audience
and i think that's what i would define
success as
personally a lot of people just try to
shoot for the stars or whatever but i
think definitely just having uh
uh success could just be making a living
wage
right what did you mean uh dax when you
asked
i i think that those answers combined
they're perfect
because i was meaning like traditional
how do you become number one
yeah that's how i interpreted it what
yeah that's how i interpreted
it but yeah the definition of success is
everything in life
it is every how do you define success
just being happy are you successful
yeah sometimes sometimes
how do you even define happiness i mean
is that an attainable
goal even i mean what what does that
mean there's a very good
i think these are they're on tick tock
and also instagram there's a guy who
goes around
asking complete strangers just cold
calls him and says hey
like what uh or are you happy
he just goes up to him and asks random
people that and you get
quite a depth of answers from people he
talks to some homeless people
who are smiling ear to ear and they're
like yeah i'm living on the beach this
is awesome
i you know i love my life there's other
people who are a little bit more like uh
like to themselves and like don't really
want to share or feel like it's too
personal to ask
are you happy um worth checking out i
don't know the name of this
interesting yeah but dex you were saying
you define happiness you said by just
feeling good
oh that's probably not like specific
enough but like
like good there's like like a lot of
things that go into it
but like good and healthy and
satisfaction on like that maslow's
pyramid thing
ah the pyramid of uh like
shelters at the bottom kind of yeah yeah
got it
but you i guess you feel at least i
learned from through the documentary
that your your income is a little
unstable right
that's kind of maybe the one factor yeah
that can really mess with
your happiness if you're stressed about
money all the time so
fortunately i haven't i could have been
so stressed with corona stuff if
unemployment didn't come through and if
i got sick too so luckily
stayed healthy and got that money and so
uh good for the next few months because
it paid me more than enough
so i've just been buying food and
nothing else so
saved up a little and then we'll see
what happens
yeah but yeah i've had
lots of money before and no money at all
and um
and so yeah it's more fun to have money
yeah i heard that you were
you were paid you you were in two movies
uh 21 jump street and
and uh what was the other one called
project x
and you said you were paid enough that
you lived off the money for like five
years right
yeah well i was also in uh a few other
movies but those were the big ones that
i got paid the most for
are you uh feel free not to answer but
i'm curious um
if you could ballpark what was your the
payment for those projects you don't
have to answer by the way
oh i could tell you whatever i don't
care um so i probably got paid like
like 30 000 or 40 000 when i was filming
them
and then i didn't know i would get
residuals checks so
a couple years later i started to get a
random residuals check
so that started out really big so
probably
overall probably like three hundred
thousand dollars from
holy movies yeah and so still i'll get
like a 200
residuals check every once in a while um
so that's cool
um um but yeah i lift off that for the
longest time
that's a lot of money yeah that that's a
lot
when you can actually get it but then
it's just so hard to get and auditions
suck
and yeah why is it it's it's
it's you've been through such a roller
coaster yeah so interesting
yeah yeah highs and lows right
yeah yeah how was it you must ask
yourself how was it
that you got cast in these two really
you know successful roles and then
suddenly like you were unable to find
work i mean why is that do
you must ask yourself i just started to
suffer auditions
like the first one was really good
because you didn't really have to be a
good actor because you're like just
like project x that was like a good
act limit at getting acclimated uh
to acting because uh like you're allowed
to just like look at the camera
and like film and like um so that was
the perfect first roll
uh and then 21 junk street came like
a year later even though they were
released at the same time um
and then uh i got really close on like
we are the millers i got like second
place um
uh like and i even went to an audition
with jason sudeikis
i got really close on this ryan gosling
movie that he made um but i don't think
many people saw it but
i did a lot of auditions and christina
hendricks was gonna play my mom
and then um i then i got close on maybe
one other movie and then
i just started to do really really bad
in auditions like i couldn't
memorize my lines and mess up all the
time um
and so
then i started writing screenplays i've
written a lot of screenplays
uh because then you just make your own
movie act in your own movie
make a game show you think you got
psyched out maybe a little bit from the
all the rejection and then started
getting getting in your head
like why do you think you started
messing up the auditions
i don't know yeah i don't know well some
some of them were good but
maybe they just wanted a different
person or something but now i just i
don't get auditions
um but uh i don't really mind because i
like making my own videos and
stuff and like even made my own
documentary
before it's kind of boring the one i
made i ian's is really
exciting and great uh uh
and not boring uh are you talking about
the one about youtube
max's documentary is good yeah you're
talking about about the kickstarter
yes i made a kickstarter for one uh well
i made it for
yeah documentary with an invention yeah
i watched that actually i wanted to ask
you about that
you made a documentary about invention
you made
for an indoor garden
it was funded and you made your dot but
the kickstarter weirdly was for the
documentary
right not for the product yeah you were
very specific about that
yeah yeah is that when you make a
kickstarter you have to
promise a product uh so i
uh promised backers that i would give
them a documentary and actually
i said it's boring but i like it um but
um
but it is kind of slow um but
i you have to promise to make something
for them so i said i would make a
documentary
if they let me use a portion of the
documentary budget to make my invention
because uh that was like the first time
i get money was like
super tight for me so i was trying to
like figure out a way to like
get rich quick essentially um and so
it's just kind of just like a scrambling
shot in the dark
uh it's a great idea which is why it's
been made since then and
uh and it's similar to hydroponics but
it doesn't have a
water like it's not based on water or
whatever it's more like self-watering
and stuff
and so i think there's like now been
plenty of things made similarly to it
um and uh ultimately
like who cares because then in the end i
got to make a documentary
at the very least about it um so
win-win but then i had to get it
i had to worry about money still for a
little while but now you you posted
online
that somebody had stolen your invention
and it was in stores
uh yeah yeah so when someone emailed me
that macy's is selling
the exact product and i've seen it
plenty of places since then like now
people keep
sending it to me do you think you were
the genesis for this
concept do you think people still i
think it's easy to get caught up in your
own head
at times especially if you're feeling
stressed about other stuff so i made
that
that video in this scrambling moment uh
and then i just posted it thinking i'll
delete it later like i was about to go
to work
and then uh
so i think probably that you know two
people in different parts of the world
can have the exact same idea and start
working at
on the same time on it at the same time
or they could have even been working on
it before me and i never knew it so
i think i think yeah like at the time
like oh they stole my idea whatever but
i don't i don't think have you followed
the success of any of those products do
you think
i i have a feeling that they're probably
not getting rich off that idea
yeah but i think it does have a lot of
potential like i think it would be
awesome awesome especially
in a pandemic to be able to pick your
food out of your own house like like if
you're into vegetables
um but
yeah the problem i came up against is
just the technology is so hard
but i think like everyone had so many
doubts when i would go ask people's
opinion
which is really helpful but also like
you have to kind of ignore them
sometimes
in order to innovate
do you have any other ideas that you
want to put out there that people can
steal
right now uh
no no well i have some ideas but i don't
want it you don't want to put them out
there yeah i don't do that
i i had another idea that i started
working on
uh and that didn't really pan out though
it could eventually someday but that's
kind of
similarly led to a book that i want to
write
so like i don't know like that's why i
always just do it anyways because
you never know what can come out of it
right you
ha you have contemporaries on youtube
like bo burnham who has gone on to uh
i've met him before
a few times uh to gone on to great
success as you know
when you look to someone like bo burnham
do you maybe
how do you feel do you wonder maybe if
you got left behind somehow
or do are you envious in any way of of
the success he's found
i mean dude like no he's super talented
uh people like charlie
i feel less excited like there's some
people who aren't that talented
um that i never mind about the last
thing but like
what did you say charlie who
it's more like an inside joke
i mean it's one of those things it's
it's in your book so you can give it
context
yeah yeah so i i just kind of hated on
him for a second in my book
what's his last name like charlie what
he's probably he's probably really
talented
really talented charlie hooth but he
used to send me hate messages on youtube
so i wrote a i wrote a hate chapter
about him in my book because
i was like feeling really bitter at the
time so kind of exactly what you were
just describing it's like oh man this
person got more famous than me
so go burnham um wait who's charlie
booth i'm sorry to interrupt you i just
want to know who that is
he's a very handsome young man who's a
singer and oh here he is he does songs
with meghan trainor and wiz khalifa
and what kind of messages would he send
you like
your voice sucks your singing sucks why
would he sound that just to be
just to be cruel well he was i think
he's probably around the same age as dax
at the time
yeah the only reason i even like
remembered remembered it because he had
a strange last name so
years later whenever i saw that name
again i was like oh my god
that's why i couldn't figure it out
booth yeah but he's actually very
talented i have nothing against him and
i regret
writing that chapter has he ever
apologized to you
no he doesn't he probably doesn't
remember well hold on
charlie i think we have a beef just out
there
but bo burnham super talented and uh
would you like an apology from charlie
what would you like an apology from
charlie puth
yeah i would take it but i'm also kind
of harassing him probably right now but
also
maybe he should maybe he should yeah
okay i think this is good i mean
charlie puth i think needs to reckon
with his past
yeah charlie puth was a uh a young
youtuber at the time i think he made uh
like outro music for shane dawson and
some other
youtubers at the time um so he's been
around for a while and i think during
that time he was just very young
and uh didn't appre appreciate dax's
vocals yeah because i suck at singing
and and
it's probably annoying if you're really
talented and working hard at something
and someone who sucks is getting more
attention
uh uh but at the time i wasn't like i
i was trying to sing like good but i
just sucked sure but he doesn't need to
go out of his way to uh
to be no yeah it doesn't necessarily
justify being a hater but also like when
someone's
15 like whatever
but what if people went and told him his
music his voice sucks would you be okay
with that
no let's let's this is a good chance for
me to set an example for people
so i forgive him
i love your i don't know his music
really but i'm sure it's great
and his voice does sound good in that
song see you again
very good falsetto
and i also
can't get mad that he's more popular
than me because i quit making videos at
a certain point so
that's like my problem well um
i've really enjoyed spending time with
with both of you
dax i'm really happy that um
i feel like a lot of people are going to
um
are going to be checking you know a lot
of people are going to be checking
checking in on you and i think a lot of
people are going to like what they see
they're going to find an interesting man
with a lot of interesting insights
a talented author whose books are on
amazon right now
have good reviews on amazon too
obviously we haven't had time to read
them we haven't got them yet but
i noticed ice cream man has got all five
stars across the board so clearly
you have a knack for for literature
and um well it's been a joy it's been a
pleasure i've enjoyed having you both on
ian's documentary is obviously up now
ice cream man no the and we have with us
ice the ice cream man no longer
dax flame no longer the ice cream no
he's he's forever the ice cream man i
mean
immortalized in in uh literature
yeah sounds better than the unemployment
man
yeah but it's on amazon so how's the
how's the rate when someone buys that
book do you get most of the money
i sell it for eight dollars and i get
two dollars and 35 cents on that one i
sell my other book for ten dollars
uh and i get three dollars and fifty
cents or something like that and i'll
sell my next book for eight dollars also
um print on demand so it's good yeah
i bet it will sell who's making all the
money you only get two bucks
well it's print on demand so you don't
need to
yeah that's also amazon which is a bit
of a racket
that's fine i would assume you'd make
more than that per per book
but the books the books are very awesome
i've i don't read a lot of books
and i've read both of them to completion
they are
very funny that's really cool thanks
thanks yeah i have a feeling you have a
knack as a as an author my
my my hunch is that you
could be a very successful author
and i think you should you should keep
pursuing that that's my hunch anyway
for whatever it's worth thank you thank
you
but man you're gonna have to sell a lot
of [ __ ] books at two dollars a pop
uh if you want uh um more than two
dollars a pop to go to dax we do have a
sabotage t-shirt that we are splitting
the revenue with that that's
awesome that's great yeah that's great
so yeah just better margins for everyone
on that
yeah i'm gonna buy a couple of those i'm
gonna buy one for the whole crew after
this
i should have i should well i couldn't
have one for them to all shoot or one
for each of them
yeah well we wouldn't really watch yeah
we would rotate
every podcast um
well i just want to say again that i
really loved the documentary
and i love that you're going in this
direction ian
yeah love to see it it's really great
and do it without people like dax and
all the other youtubers who you know
pitched in yeah
oh and uh shout out to uh brett benowitz
um he's he was the uh the
other participant in smoothie game
smoothie madness oh right he was a great
supporter
yeah yeah um him and leticia were
awesome
it was super surprising brett was like
the only nice person on hollywood
boulevard
i know i noticed that that was something
huh yeah he he
gave us the time of day he would have
kept talking to us for longer but he had
some place he had to be and uh yeah he's
making music
he's acting he's he's cool so uh
you know if you follow him on social
media or anything just be respectful and
know that he's you know he does a lot of
other stuff
okay fantastic well dax i wish you well
i
look forward to what's next from you and
ian the same goes for you
thank you guys both for joining us this
has been the h3 podcast
experience transcendental experience um
joe rogan's show is frankly not that
good
if his is an experience then mine is a
is another dimension of being i mean
there's no other way to compare them are
you people are comparing
people always compare us they say oh i
wonder which one which shows better
give you uh you know an extra thousand
episodes
and and i think you'll overtake them you
heard it here
[Applause]
i appreciate yeah he's up to like 1500 f
so we he has more experience than us
if his show's better it's just it's only
for that
uh i think i'm more talented uh
anyway guys thank you all for watching
and what was his name charlie puth yes
we forgive him all right thank you
everybody
that's a wrap all right
[Music]